10e place alors celle là de la deuxième
la deuxième chose c'est que quand
j'entends les gens de la france
insoumise
voilà nous dire que c'est un le m'étais
fait ça en clair c'est un royaliste à
isserpent la politique non non mais les
gens les reds est la politique des mes
mecs les mêmes mecs qui n'ont pas un mot
quand il s'agit de prendre parti j'ai
pris des billets seront d'accord avec
toi
les mecs qui qualisol le repos avec
déséquilibré est notamment récolté 404
ils ont d articuler les drapeaux
soviétiques qui est complètement
légitime rod fanni contre les
groupuscules genre bien servi je crois
que tu n'as pu gêner la commission
pourquoi parce que tu me fatigues non je
te le dis on donne la parole je chantais
tout ça ça contredit non seulement passé
avec david guion contradictoires tenus
non je sors pas je vais tourner non non
non mais je te dis je suis pas moi sans
rien
les sortir le
le bossu parler aux gens je vais
t'expliquer quelque chose on n'est pas
d'accord avec tout ce que dit la france
a soumis si j'ai l'impression que si je
l'étais d'equity l'abruti c'est vrai
j'ai dû laisser moi de parler parce que
je t'explique tu es toujours hors sujet
non je suis politis toujours le truc je
t'ai dit le 5 août non non je suis je
t'ai dit je crois est une fois de jeu de
dire que je suis pas sûr a soumis les
papilles des gens qu'on apprend t-on
dame est juste très rapidement parce qu'
il manque pratiquement il dit que la
france est soumise
moi quand zemmour il s'est fait gifler
j'ai twitté pour paris mais oui donc
taisez vous non non pas parce que votre
pote vous êtes toujours comme cul et
chemise et là on dirait minus et ça
c'est vraiment arrêter généraux désolé
mais c'est de façon parler tu suces n'a
jamais cessé tu c'est une remarque est
très désobligeantes très sexiste de ton
plus que tu te fasses un hétéro
ce soir et je t'aime beaucoup ta côté de
la planète je sais pas côté de la fnac
tu as politisé je veux dire nous ici on
est français subissent ni rennes ni au
milieu se soient battus bien plus ouvert
que donc arrête nous faire chier